[Music]
it's a KNE when you know they're waiting
for you to choke it's a knife when a
journalist doesn't miss quot it's a
knife when a friend is suddenly stepping
on your throat it's enough when they say
that you've been doing things you don't
it's KN when your old friends hate your
new friends when somebody says Charlie I
think You' totally changed it's a knif
when somebody say cuz they like the old
me and not the new me and I'm like who
the is she cuz it's a knife when
you're finally on top cuzic be the next
step CU they want to see you fall to the
bottom it's a knife when you're finally
on top cuz Lally The Next Step they want
to see you fall it's a night one it's a
night one it's a nice one I just a nice
one it's a nice one it's a
knife it's a knife when you know the
counting on your mistakes it's a knife
when you're so pretty they think it must
be fake it's a knife when they your body
on the it's a knife when they won't
believe you why should you
explain the mean the
nice says S I think you totally
Chang somebody s like the old me and not
the new me I'm like f she cuz it's a
knif when you're finally on top cuz the
next episode want to see you fall to the
bottom it's a knife when you finally on
top the they want to see you fall it's a
one it's Ace one it's a
one it's one
[Music]
all this expectation
is all the things I've said are just a
high all this expectation is a
nice yeah
[Music]
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
session goodness only knows I enjoyed
Cutting Loose and uh performing to that
song especially with these the awesome
LED sock po I was using in that video If
you want to get a hold of a set of these
for yourself you can do so by using the
promo code Drex Factor over at neof flow
art.com that'll get you a discount on
your order and it helps out the channel
so everybody wins uh thank you so much
to neop and sock PO for sponsoring this
video and giving me an excuse to go out
and flow with some awesome looking LED
poy uh speaking of thank yous I owe big
thank yous to the Friends of the channel
uh big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca
flow fests flow toys pyro Tera light
toys and Ultra poy for helping to make
the videos on this channel possible you
can learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that I have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel That is Becca
becklen thank you so much for supporting
my channel my work and my mission and of
course this video and all the videos on
on this channel would not exist were it
not for the amazing support of my
wonderful backers on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you you all rock
and if you enjoy the videos that I
create and you'd like to see me make
more of them the easiest way to make
that happen is to go sign up to support
me over on patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor pooy there you
can get access to a whole host of
amazing rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you finally if
you uh just can't get enough of these
flow sessions of me spinning with
various sets of props I'll go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of videos
I've done featuring other props and
other songs down in the description as
well as up on screen thanks so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
yourself today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now and
happy holidays peace